معارك ساخنه ومستعره في المحور الشمالي من
مقاطعه دانيس حيث مازالت قوات بادنر تطوق
مدينه باخبط من النواحي الشماليه
والجنوبيه والشرقيه وتحاول اقتحام المدينه
من المحور الجنوبي قتال شوارع في ذلك
المحور بالفعل تشير مصادر ايضا الى
استقدام الجيش الاوكراني لاعداد كبيره من
الجنود والاليات العسكريه وتاسيس قاعده
عسكريه غرب مدينه باخمط في منطقه او مدينه
تدعى سوفيان ايضا هناك نفي من الجيش
الاوكراني الانسحاب من مدينه
بلاجاباتنا شمال المقاطعه حيث اعلنت قوات
بان سيطرتها على هذه البلده معارك ساخنه
وضاريه في المحور النار المثلث الناري بين
لوغانس ودانيسكو
الهجمات المتبادله ما بين الجيشين
الاوكراني والروسي وتشير المصادر الى
استقدام حشود كبيره من الجيش الاوكراني
واليات في ذلك المحور من اجل التقدم حيث
تمركز الجيش الروسي